en pologne plusieurs hôtels restaurants
et bars annonce avoir ouvert ce lundi
malgré les restrictions pour lutter
contre locaux vides 19
ce mouvement de rébellion a commencé
dans les régions montagneuses du sud du
pays qui vivent principalement du
tourisme hivernal
c'est donc ici qu'a été lancé ces
derniers jours le veto des montagnards
après l'annnonce de la prolongation des
mesures sanitaires jusqu'à fin janvier
j'ai des informations provenant de
grands entrepreneurs et propriétaires de
chaînes hôtelières de stations de ski et
de piscines selon lesquelles d'ici ce
week-end ou même plutôt une grande
partie de leur activité sera ouverte
ouvrir ses portes malgré le confinement
partiel imposé par le gouvernement
les propriétaires des établissements
jouent gros la police et l'inspection
sanitaire peuvent à tout moment
intervenir et infliger des amendes de
30000 sothys environ 6600 euros
nous contesterons cette amende en
justice en espérant qu'elle soit annulée
car elle n'est pas constitutionnelle
la constitution polonaise prévoit que
l'activité économique peut être
uniquement restreinte par une loi
or il n'ya pas de loi ni d'état
d'urgence
ces entrepreneurs jugent le soutien
financier de l'état bien insuffisant en
quelques jours le slogan on ouvre à
fleury sur les réseaux sociaux les
établissements invitant les clients à
revenir
une carte interactive du pays a même été
créé pour recenser les lieux